hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
we've all heard of the clockwork
universe right this is the idea that
came into physics post isaac newton and
pierre simone laplace the idea if you
knew everything was going on in the
universe you could predict exactly what
would happen next of course the
clockwork universe isn't
the current paradigm for thinking about
physics because of quantum mechanics
which came about in the early 20th
century we know that the world as we
observe it is not deterministic
there is unpredictable quantum
randomness in the world but that quantum
randomness is not the first time that
randomness or probability popped up in
the history of physics there's also
famously in the late 19th century
the advent of statistical mechanics we
had thermodynamics we were inventing in
the 19th century putting together the
theory of thermodynamics the science of
heat and how different kinds of fluids
and gases pushed on each other and did
work and dissipated entropy and all that
stuff and then maxwell and boltzmann and
their collaborators figured out that you
could understand thermodynamics if you
believed in atoms and molecules if you
believed that things you thought of as a
fluid or a solid are actually many many
many little particles
and these particles were more likely to
behave in some ways than others so
probability came in the fact that
entropy increases over time is not an
airtight rule in boltzmann's way of
thinking about it it's just very very
very likely people didn't like this at
the time there were strong strong
objections but now it's the accepted
lore so you might think that statistical
mechanics which involves probability and
quantum mechanics which involves
probability would be close bed fellows
right they'd be natural partners and you
would think about quantum statistical
mechanics and its implications for
either pure science or for technology or
what have you
well they are natural
fellow travelers but it's taken a long
time for scientists to really dig into
the essence of quantum statistical
mechanics how do you combine together
the idea of quantum mechanics replacing
particles and fields with wave functions
and observations with probability
outcomes with statistical mechanics the
idea that you don't know exactly what
the system is doing you can only make
probabilistic assertions about what's
going to happen next today's guest
nicole younger halpern is a leading
expert a very young person but
nevertheless leading in the dawning
science of quantum statistical mechanics
and thermodynamics and its relationship
to things like information theory how
much do you know about a system
and the fact that it combines crazy
radical ideas with potentially real
world experimental implications has
inspired nicole to name her own field
quantum steampunk and she has a new book
out called quantum steampunk all about
this revolution that's been going on for
no more than 20 or 30 years i would say
in physics where we're really
understanding the frontier of
statistical mechanics with quantum at
the heart of it and so again it has both
implications for how we think about the
fundamental nature of reality right
because that's what quantum mechanics is
and maybe
implications for things like how
biophysics works right how dna works or
maybe for nanotechnology for building
little machines at these tiny scales
thermodynamics and statistical mechanics
were driven by the urge to understand
steam engines
at some sense in some way
quantum thermodynamics is going to be
building steam engines at the molecular
scale thus quantum steampunk and also
the outfits are really really cool so
this is a fun conversation
cutting-edge science going on here but
in a slightly different vein that we've
had previously on the podcast i'll give
you uh our occasional reminder that we
have a website preposterousuniverse.com
where you can find show notes
transcripts for every episode you can
search through them etc all the archival
episodes are just as awesome now as they
were when we recorded them and there is
a patreon that if you want to support
mindscape you can go to patreon.com
sean m carroll and you get both ad-free
versions of the podcast episodes plus
it's the patreon supporters that get to
ask questions for the monthly ask me
anything episodes so plenty of reason to
join the patreon although i would argue
that the reason to do it is less
for tangible benefits than for the
intangible benefit of being part of the
community of mindscape supporters we
talk on the patreon page there are
comments there's a back and forth
there's a whole back channel you don't
know about if you're not a patreon
supporter so join up today
patreon.comcarroll
and even if you don't that's okay we
still love you you can still enjoy the
episode let's go
[Music]
nicole younger helper and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
thank you it's a delight to be here
i wanted to take advantage of having you
here uh you have this wonderful quantum
steampunk label for both your research
and your new book and obviously both
those words are very evocative in very
different ways i had to laugh a little
bit because when i wrote my book about
quantum mechanics
about many worlds etc i went to amazon
and i looked for word for books with the
word quantum in them and i didn't find
that because it hadn't didn't exist yet
but i did find quantum leadership
quantum yoga quantum healing etc so
you're you're joining a long
not so very
dignified uh history of using the word
quantum mechanics but you're using in a
much more respectable way
that's the intent
but i
before we get to the quantum part wanted
to think about the thermodynamic part of
what you do i mean actually maybe why
don't you just define what you mean by
quantum steampunk and then then we'll
back up a little bit and lay some
groundwork okay
well steampunk is a genre of literature
art and film
it's a genre that combines victorian
settings from the 1800s so
some of the earliest factories very
smoky foggy london the wild wild west
men and top hats
and puts those together with futuristic
technologies like time machines
dirigibles and automata
so this is a genre of sci-fi
but i see it as really coming to life in
science that's happening now at the
intersection of
quantum physics information theory and
thermodynamics of thermodynamics is the
study of energy and it was developed
during the 1800s motivated by those
smoky factories the steam engines that
were driving them
so
quantum thermodynamics this
bringing together of these three fields
is partially victorian but quantum
information is part of the science and
technology of the future people are
building quantum computers now so i see
quantum steampunk as
really the the spirit of quantum
thermodynamics and as sharing is it's
aesthetic with this genre of literature
art and film and especially the word
steam is just a wonderful fit because
like like you say that was the origin of
thermodynamics like these days we think
of thermodynamics in terms of entropy
and the arrow time and stuff like that
depending on where you come from but it
was really all about building steam
engines back in the day right
yes people wanted to be able to pump
water out of mines in england
and i'm told and i've often related this
but maybe i don't know if you have
better insight on the history that saji
carnot
of carnot cycle fame one of the one of
the pioneers of uh thermodynamics was
mostly motivated by his annoyance that
british steam engines were so much
better than french steam engines have
you ever heard that i can imagine that
i haven't heard that but i can well
imagine that
yeah there's a certain nationalistic
pride there and so he invented you know
he so in a very french fashion he said
well let's invent the perfect steam
engine and then realize that there would
always be some dissipation a lot of the
second law so
good this is a perfect uh excuse for me
to uh
talk about thermodynamics because you
know it's crucially important part of
science
in some ways i think that thermodynamics
is kind of
not given as much respect among
professional physicists as it should i
mean we all love the laws of
thermodynamics but it's not quite
considered
a sub-discipline you have particle
physicists you have astrophysicists
there's not a lot of people
at least in the modern u.s culture that
i'm aware of who are specializing in
thermodynamics or statistical mechanics
i discussed that a little bit in the
book
quantum thermodynamics has its root in
the 1930s
right after people
discovered quantum theory
but it's really blossomed over the past
10 or so years and a lot of the energy
has come from
europe canada singapore outside the us
so the us has taken a while to catch on
which is ironic because there was also
another spurt of growth in quantum
thermodynamics during the 1980s and a
lot of those developments did happen in
the us but over the past 10 years or so
there was a lot less quantum
thermodynamics activity in the us
and so that's one reason why i
considered going elsewhere for grad
school actually
europe has this
millennia old wonderful tradition of
philosophy and
the u.s has had
let's say uh
at least a stereotype of
efficiency
and productivity and applications
so the nature of the quantum science
done in the us has been very different
and quantum thermodynamics has
historically especially
at the beginning of its lifetime
been more
abstract mathematical and
philosophically oriented
recently there have been
lots of connections with experiments
some of my colleagues and i have worked
to build bridges with the fields that
are more developed in the u.s atomic
molecular and optical physics canon's
matter high energy physics and so now
there's a lot more interest and
enthusiasm in the us for quantum
thermodynamics and
in association with that thermodynamics
i think well it's it's ironic right
because like we just said thermodynamics
itself minus the quantum part classical
thermodynamics from the 19th century
was the paradigmatic uh
applied science it was it really was
almost engineering i mean can you tell
us a little bit about
the your favorite stories of the origins
of thermodynamics i mean how do you
think about that those developments over
the 1800s which were so influential some
people have we discussed as we discussed
we're interested in
seeing how efficiently engines could
power factories and pump water out of
mines
but these
practical questions can't really be
considered without the fundamental
questions that go along with them for
instance esteem is a
relatively large classical system you
can think about it without having to
think about individual particles
but some thermodynamicists thought it
worthwhile to think about individual
particles
atomism had
basically been established by then but
still people some people didn't like
atomism and some thermodynamicists said
we can describe
a lot of
the changes coming about in the world
during the industrial revolution by just
referring to large-scale properties of
systems like energy temperature and
pressure we have no need to talk about
these invisible particles that you can't
even see it's unscientific for you to
talk about them and they sort of beat
down on the thermodynamicists who wanted
to think about individual particles but
fortunately
those other thermodynamicists
did have their say and they ended up
being right that there are individual
particles out there
and that's so we can even start to see
the legacy of quantum theory in
thermodynamics that's true yeah i mean
there's definitely was uh the hints of
atoms and particles that eventually grew
into quantum theory i'm wondering if
maybe you know we've all heard
entropy increases over time right the
second law of thermodynamics and the
closed system entropy goes up but that
was not the formulation that people had
back in saji carnot's time right he
didn't know about the word entropy he
thought about cycles and engines and so
can can you sort of put us back in that
mindset of someone who thinks about
thermodynamics in terms of cycles and
engines and what was his what was
carnot's big thing that he explained to
us there are multiple ways of casting
the second law of thermodynamics
one is very closely related to
carnot's engine which as you mentioned
is an idealized engine
it is
some
working medium that has contact with two
different
um large bodies we call them heat baths
you can also call them environments but
i like that her meat baths because it
makes me think of those open loofas and
so on
so this engine can contact two different
heat baths
one is hot one is colds
and
the engine undergoes a cycle a sequence
of four different steps
and at the end of the cycle the engine
ends up in the same configuration the
same state as it was at the beginning
that's why we call it a cycle because
the four steps close the engine ends up
back where it was however the rest of
the world has changed during the cycle
the engine performs work useful energy
on some other system so it might be
lifting a weight or turning a paddle
wheel
and meanwhile energy has
flowed between those two
heat baths so the hot bath gets a little
bit cooler and the cold bath gets a
little bit warmer
so carno calculated the best possible
efficiency achievable by this engine or
by any engine that's in contact with
just two different heat baths of two
different temperatures
and so his
this optimal efficiency is called the
carnot bound or the carnot limit
when we
develop new engine cycles
including in quantum thermodynamics
to evaluate how well the engine performs
we'll often calculate the efficiency and
then double check that if our engine
satisfies carnot assumptions it does not
break the carnot bound because if our
engine broke the cardo bound then we
would basically be breaking the second
law of thermodynamics and certainly we
would have done something wrong
or really really important but actually
let me yes with very very low
probability very low probability i know
that we have our priors on these things
but this is peaking ahead a little bit
but of course we're going to eventually
talk about the quantum side of things
is
are the results of carnot etc still just
as true in the quantum realm or once we
have quantum mechanics can we do better
than a car no efficiency one might hope
that quantum theory could get around
carnot's bound to my knowledge karno's
bound has not been broken
and there are many papers with many
proposals of engines classical and
quantum
and in these papers the authors check
yes my engine obeys the carno bound
however there are ways to bend around
the carno bound so you could propose an
engine that's on the face of it might
seem like it should obey the carno bound
but actually
accesses some slightly different
resource
like
a certain quantum resource that
really
doesn't enable the engine to fall under
the assumptions of cardo and so you can
quote unquote break the carno bone but
actually you're just bending around it
keeping a better efficiency all right
and so back to the classical world of
the 1800s
you've used words or there are words
hanging around in the background here
that would be worth digging into namely
work and heat
and these were tough for me when i was
first learning thermodynamics i mean
clearly we need to understand these two
different forms of energy
and i i think that no one really does or
at least that i think that people
disagree about what the best way of
thinking about these things are like do
you have a favorite way of of saying
what is work and what is heat
work and heat are the two types of
energy that are being transferred
between two different bodies
and
my way of thinking about them
is partially a little loose and
intuitive and then partially we can put
some math to
say
the work that is performed and then say
everything that's not covered by this
bath is heat so
work is
energy that's being transferred that's
directly useful you can directly harness
it to
push a rock up a hill or charge a
battery it's in a sense coordinated
whereas heat is
random energy so it's uncoordinated it's
not doing something useful although if
you wanted to then you could use it in
conjunction with an engine to do
something more useful to turn it into
work
so heat is more the random jiggling
around of molecules
i think yeah i think heat makes sense
and it even makes sense how you can turn
heat into useful work i mean that's
literally what happens in an internal
combustion engine right you
fire some piston you know the gas
ignites and it heats up and pushes the
piston
uh but the the
work part is always a bit more subtle
especially because like you just did
it's so often defined in terms of
usefulness
and that seems a bit anthropocentric
right it seems like human beings and
their
ideas about what is isn't is not useful
or somehow creeping into this
fundamental law of physics but but
there's also the the related concepts of
coordination which you just used or
organized forms of energy you know there
are there rigorous ways of defining
the sense in which certain kinds of
energy or certain energetic
substances can be organized and
therefore we call that energy work
rather than heat
we
have in thermodynamics a set of
thermodynamic variables so entropy
temperature pressure
volume
particle number chemical potential
some of these numbers are
extensive they grow with the size of the
system
for instance you can have some material
that takes up some volume if you
take another copy of the material and
put it right next to the first copy then
you've doubled the volume so those are
the extensive parameters then there are
intensive parameters that don't scale in
that way for instance if you have one
material at some temperature and you
take another copy of the material and
put it right next to the first copy
everything is still at the same
temperature
and
we do work when we
change those extensive parameters for
example we could have a gas in a box our
favorite example of steam
that gas could be capped with a piston
and if the gas is expanding against the
piston so that it's increasing its
volume then the gas is performing work
against the piston
even if it's not particularly useful for
me personally to have the piston move
upward
got it okay good yeah so it's not really
as anthropocentric as it sounds
um but is is this question of
a a
clear bright line between heat and work
is that like a useful thing to think
about we real do do the experts really
truly understand it once and for all or
is it kind of the thing where
researchers are still quibbling over it
researchers definitely quibble over it
in quantum thermodynamics i've heard
less quibbling in classical
thermodynamics but there could be
quibbling that i'm i haven't heard good
i know i think that gives us the the
background we need and then there are of
course i want to get on the table the
idea of refrigerators which are somehow
uh related to engines but backwards
yes exactly we could take for instance
carnot's cycle
that moves heat from the hot bath to the
cold bath and run it backward we would
be moving heat from the cold bath to the
hot bath to
cool down the cold baths to
keep last last night leftover is cool
but this requires some energy is the
point like it's never going to happen
spontaneously that would violate the
second law
exactly if we want to run carnot's
engine backward then instead of getting
work out of the cycle we have to put
work into the cycle
yeah okay good uh and the so the next
big thing so that that that's how people
were thinking like in the first half of
the
18th 1800s 19th century the second half
like you already alluded to atoms came
on the scene right in statistical
mechanics and so i think probably people
are somewhat familiar with that basic
idea that really gases are made of atoms
etc but what really is interesting like
the profound philosophical move is that
probability and information come into
the game can you say a little bit about
that sort of conceptual shift in how
thermodynamics was thought about
thermodynamics originally was thought
about in terms of these large-scale
quantities that characterize systems the
ones that i just mentioned external and
internal
excuse me extensive and intensive
parameters like energy temperature and
pressure
but
you can go farther and think about some
material of many many particles as
excuse me some large material as
consisting of many many particles
and in principle if you
know some of the theories that we have a
good handle on in physics today
including quantum mechanics then you
could imagine describing all of those
particles individually and all of those
particles interactions
and in principle if you had enough
computing power which you won't
then you could
recover the
large-scale behaviors of as large a
material as you please
but
again this is very difficult to do and
also it's not necessarily the most
useful
because
when we
study thermodynamic behaviors of
materials we don't really care about
what all the little particles are doing
we're more interested in what the
material is doing which is well
described in many cases by
average behaviors of the particles and
we can also
not knowing exactly what the particles
are doing use probabilities
to say
there is probably
the particles are have some probability
of being here with these momenta and
some probability of being there with
those momenta we don't know but we don't
actually need to know in order to
recover the large-scale behaviors of the
material
so did people
in
1870 think in terms of information
theory at all they certainly began to
think in terms of probability people
like maxwell and boltzmann etc there are
certainly the beginnings of
information theory there for instance
boltzmann's h function
is
a manifestation of entropy which played
a very important role in information
theory
during the 20th century as invented by
claude shannon
claude shannon
explained the father of information
theory explained why he when he came up
with some function in information theory
that quantified uncertainty about
something he wasn't sure what to call it
and he got advice from his friend john
von neumann the great hungarian
american mathematical physicist and von
neumann said this thing you should call
it entropy because
um well it's already been called that in
statistical mechanics it already exists
and also no one really understands
entropy so in a debate you will always
have the advantage
i don't know how many debates shannon
got into but i hope that he did get the
advantage there but but i don't want to
sort of
gloss over the profoundness of this move
right i mean we start by talking about
steam engines and everyone thinks that
you know there's something that's going
to happen when you light the spark in
your piston but now
you've re formulated everything in terms
of information like you know entropy is
a measure of how much we don't know
about the microscopic state of a system
how do you reconcile in your in your
soul you know how information helps
pistons move that's a good question
suppose there are multiple ways to
approach this question
and one way is thermodynamics is an
operational theory it is about agents
who run engines who want to cool systems
down or to charge batteries so they want
to accomplish goals
and they can accomplish goals only
insofar as they have the information
about where a gas is compressed or
and so
information and the gas's entropy
should come into play when we think
about thermodynamics
okay that makes sense i mean i guess
let's let's let's make it even more
specific by talking about everyone's
favorite thought experiment of maxwell's
demon right maxwell's demon in some
sense is
uh an operationalization of this
relationship between information and
thermodynamics and entropy and so forth
so uh i'll let you tell the audience
what maxwell's demon experiment is
actually supposed to tell us what it is
and what it's supposed to teach us so
james clark maxwell
who was one of the founders of
thermodynamics came up with a thought
experiment in which he challenged the
second law he said suppose that there is
a gas in a box our favorite system in
thermodynamics
there is
a partition dividing the box in half
there's a little door in the partition
and there's what he called a finite
being his colleagues named it a demon
which is probably the term that maxwell
should have used because it caught on so
well
there's a demon who can open and close
the door
this demon
will
see
particles moving at a very high speed
coming let's say from the right and
we'll let those through
and whenever the demon sees slow-moving
particles coming from the left the demon
will let those through
but if there are any fast particles
coming through the left the demon won't
let those through the door and so on so
eventually the demon will separate out
the different particles in the gas so
that the quick molecules are on the
left-hand side of the box and the slow
molecules are on the right-hand side of
the box
the speed of a set of molecules in a gas
is directly related to
the
energy of that gas
so and in its temperature
so the demon will have separated what
used to be just one uniform gas which is
everywhere at just one temperature into
two different gases one hot and one cold
then the daemon could
take carnot's idea and run an engine
cycle and from this temperature
difference extracts useful work so the
two gases over the course of the engine
cycle will come to be at the same
temperature or after many many cycles
so the demon will have extracted work
while returning the whole gas to the
same uniform temperature and then the
demon could do this entire thing again
and again and again so the demon could
run a
perpetual motion machine
and extract as much work as he wanted
that
idea violates the second law of
thermodynamics so what is wrong with
maxwell's demon why can't this maxwell
demon really operate as it operates
good so what's the answer
it took us a while right it took us a
little bit
yeah it took us an embarrassingly long
time to figure this out yes
so the
answer that is the most widely accepted
was put forth by charlie bennett near
the end of the 20th century he was
building on
the work of sealard another great
hungarian physicist and rolf landauer
there's a little bit of debate about
whether this is really satisfactory
answer but
i see quite a bit of agreements across
the physics community and i find the
answer satisfying personally so
bennett proposed that the answer is
this demon
actually records information about which
particles are moving quickly and so
where the hot gas ends up this part the
the demon
at the end suppose that the demon has
separated the gases into the gas into
two different gases and has run the
engine cycle so that there's just one
uniform gas again we would like to say
according to our story that everything
is reset so that it's exactly as it used
to be at the beginning
however the demon actually has this
memory which is now full of information
and in order to actually reset the full
system the demon needs to erase this
information from his memory
and landower showed that erasing
information costs thermodynamic work
so the work that the daemon gained by
running the engine cycle is lost in the
erasure and so the demon nets zero work
after all and can't run a perpetual
motion machine
it's interesting so you you say that
erasure
costs thermodynamic work the usual way
that i think about it is erasure
increases entropy these are probably the
same things said in different words yeah
basically okay
and that's roughly because
irreversible things increase entropy
right like if you had just the
underlying newtonian or even shorter
equation laws of physics everything is
reversible but something like erasing is
irreversible so that's where entropy has
to come in exactly good and
i guess i see why that
explanation from
uh bennett is is pretty darn good but
not entirely
satisfying i mean you know what if the
demon had a really big ledger and didn't
need to erase it for a long time i'm not
completely convinced about this yet i
mean i'm not saying that you have a
should have a better way of doing it i
think it's interesting that over a
hundred years later we still haven't
completely nailed this thing down
right and interestingly it was
just recently that experimentalists got
to the point of
checking
the qualitative or excuse me the
quantitative prediction by landauer that
indicated that the demon really would
need to expend
basically all the work that he got from
the engine cycle in order to erase his
memory
so yes there's
still a lot of discussion happening
and this is at least
tangentially related to the fact that
our laptops heat up right i mean doing
computations we we can do sorry we can
do reversible computations but typically
we don't typically we do irreversible
computations and according to landauer
that's going to heat things up it's a
fascinating connection between
information and heat
yes
we could do our computation reversibly
but we'd need an idealized system it
would run
very very very very very slowly so it
wouldn't be very practical for doing
your taxes say
and i presume that i mean landauer has a
bound like is for every
bit that you erase a certain uh entropy
is created uh are real world computers
like are the laptop that i'm using right
now close to that bound or are they more
wasteful than that our computers are way
more wasteful than that
again it was just
not too long ago that
during the 21st century that
experimentalists started
showing that
they could approach the idealization
that is landauer's limit
is this a future
frontier for computer builders to try to
be more and more efficient and come
closer to land hours bound
it is
definitely a topic that
is
an inspiration for say my community and
a topic also of practical interest to
say a colleague i have who used to be at
ibm
so it's
it's being thought about we are we are a
little a little ways away but energy
usage is
an important topic and there are a lot
of people thinking about it
i mean it's certainly true that the
computers around the world use a lot of
electricity right generate a lot of heat
i mean it's something we might imagine
we would like to do better at
yes definitely
and then okay good now we're i think
we're ready to move on to the quantum
side of things so since you've explained
thermodynamics to us please explain
quantum mechanics to us
now of course
so uh very loosely speaking quantum
physics is the physics of the very small
the electrons atoms photons or particles
of light and so on
and these systems can act in ways that
are
very different from the ways in which
the large systems from our everyday
lives connect
probably most people who have listened
to this podcast have heard about
superpositions and entanglement very
strong correlations that quantum
particles can share
we can
use these different behaviors of quantum
systems to perform certain tasks such as
solving certain computational problems
much more efficiently than we can
perform those tasks with classical
systems
similarly there are thermodynamic tasks
like the extraction of work and the
charging of batteries
that
are similar in spirit to information
processing tasks so we can ask can we
also use quantum resources to perform
those tasks better than with classical
resources
and i guess if
someone asks me what is the most
important difference between quantum
mechanics and classical mechanics my
answer would have something to do with
entanglement uh do you think of it that
way also or do you think of something
else is the most important thing and
and what is it
i certainly think of entanglement as
very closely bound up in the difference
between
classical and quantum there are many
different things that we can think of as
quantum
some of those characteristics are can be
mimicked by classical systems
for instance an atom can have only
certain amounts of energy so its energy
consists of just discrete numbers
however there are classical systems that
have at least approximately discretized
energies
entanglement is something that we don't
attribute to classical systems but
there's a very
high bar that you can set such that if
you prove that some phenomenon meets
this bar then it is truly non-classical
that bar is contextuality it's pretty
difficult to prove that something is
contextual but it can be done i think of
contextuality as at least in some cases
uh the thing behind entanglement that
makes entanglement really non-classical
and
in some cases provide speed up to
quantum computers
but i think it's much easier in many
cases to talk about entanglement and
it's also very useful so entanglement is
a
strong relationship that quantum
particles can have
i think of entanglement
are quantum particles that are entangled
as a whole greater than the sum of their
parts
there is some information in a system of
entangled particles that is not in just
one particle it's not in just the other
particle and it's not in the sum of the
two particles separately but it's sort
of between the particles it's in the
hole
and what is contextuality can you
explain that
so we would think
that if we were performing a measurement
in a lab
a measurement of
atoms or dna or anything else then
the color of my shirt doesn't matter
it's not going to affect the statistics
of the outcomes of that experiment if we
run many trials so there are
properties that
seem like they really should be
irrelevant to the statistics of the
outcomes of the measurements in an
experiment
and
in the classical world indeed the color
of my turret does not matter
but in the quantum realm
there are some properties that we would
expect to be totally irrelevant to the
statistics of measurement outcomes that
in fact aren't irrelevant
and so we could say that in quantum
theory context matters for measurement
statistics so we say that quantum theory
is contextual and classical physics is
non-contextual can you give us a
concrete example of a property that we
would expect not to matter classically
but what would matter quantum
mechanically to measurement outcomes
we can imagine having a system with
three observables three properties that
we might want to measure
and
properties a and b could
be
could
commute with each other so we can
measure the two of them simultaneously
without any problems
and similarly
um observables a and c could commute
with each other so
we can measure them both simultaneously
without problems
so we could think if we
measure
um
one of these observables then
say if we measure
um
a then whether we measure one of these
other prop uh observables really doesn't
matter and shouldn't affect the outcome
statistics
however observables b and c might
disagree with each other and we would
say that they don't commute with each
other so they can't be measured
simultaneously but you would think that
that wouldn't really affect a
but it can affect the statistics of
measurement outcomes
so
i mean this is great and fascinating but
it's also a little bit abstract i mean
uh so where do we run into this kind of
thing measuring spins or qubits or in a
quantum computer like or
like
some kind of experiment in your lab i
don't know
there are
people have shown that contextuality is
behind at least some of the speed ups
that are
achievable by quantum computers with
qubits
so that is one example where
contextuality is important
okay cool and is it i mean is it sort of
a version of entanglement or is it more
like the uncertainty principle i mean
certainly the fact that different
observables can't be measured at the
same time sounds uncertainty
principle-esque definitely and they're
all related they're all parts of quantum
physics
they
i think of contextuality again as
each of them is a very specific property
and they're all closely related one can
involve the other
contextuality is just a particularly
high bar or something for some property
or for some experiment to have such that
we can really say it's really really
non-classical yeah it's really quantum
okay good and the other interesting
thing uh to get on the table before
diving into applications is that
quantum mechanics introduces a whole new
kind of entropy or at least a new way to
have entropy entanglement brings along
with it uh a kind of entropy that we
hadn't anticipated before indeed
so if we have two particles that share
entanglements then
automatically each one of those
particles has entropy just because of
that entanglement
and can we read entanglement um is
the most popular way of measuring that
entanglement is with the von neumann
entropy named after the john von neumann
who advised claude shannon about naming
his entropy
uh yeah did that come second i mean did
van leeum invent his entropy after
shannon i don't know who came first
i'm not sure of the years um but at
least the two of them according to this
quote from claude shannon seem not to be
competitors but more helping each other
out
and can i think of it i've always i've
gone back and forth myself about this so
i have two entangled systems and like
you just said
that means that
either one of them considered by itself
has some entropy can i relate that back
to information can i say that because
it's entangled there's some information
i don't have about that subsystem unless
i include the whole shebang
exactly
there's
some information that's not in just one
of the particles or the other or in the
sum of the two measured separately but
that information is spread out across
the whole
good okay good so we have entanglement
it leads to this new kind of entropy
let's put it to work let's let's uh do
some quantum thermodynamics so i have a
list of you know different ways in which
this becomes really interesting i don't
know do you want to pick one first like
how what is the what is the sales pitch
if you're going to say like not just
thermodynamics but quantum
thermodynamics is something that's
really interesting to think about for
this reason
i think of
quantum thermodynamics as encompassing
another a number of goals and ways of
viewing it one is that
we know that quantum physics can assist
with information processing tasks like
communicating information and solving
certain computational problems there are
thermodynamic tasks analogous to
information processing tasks like
refrigerating and charging batteries
so we can imagine that quantum phenomena
might help with some of those
thermodynamic tasks
one example that i discuss in my book
is
an information-based engine
this is sealer's engine we mentioned
c-large just now when we were discussing
the resolution of maxwell's demon
paradox
so sealer showed that if you have
information and you also have a source
of heat
then you can use that information to
turn this
random uncoordinated heat into useful
work
his
initial thought experiment was about
classical gas
but you can imagine that this gas might
be classical
or quantum and as we know they're
different types of quantum particles
some are fermions like electrons and the
other atoms are the other types of
matter around us instead you can imagine
that the particles are bosons so
carriers of force or compositions of
multiple fermions
and the fermions and the bosons
have
different tendencies different
properties so you could imagine running
your engine through many many cycles
with each of these types of particles
and you would get out some amount of
work on average from each type
the amount of work that you could get
from fermions would be in
a certain setup would be zero
the amount you could get with classical
particles would be greater and the
amount that you could get with bosons
would be even greater so the
what we think of as spin statistics of
bosons can help you on average in
extracting work from an information
engine
okay that's very interesting so um
fermions are the particles that can't
pile on top of each other bosons are the
ones that like to pile on top of each
other and you're saying that we can use
that fact to beat the best possible
classical result
in principle and the basic idea comes
exactly from what you said since the
bosons will have a tendency to pile on
top of each other they'll exert a
greater pressure that's why they'll do
more work
and is this something that is
only going to be useful at the
microscopic scale or can we imagine you
know using this kind of technology and
building it up to greater and greater
sizes so that it's really like an engine
that could push a car around
we could imagine i don't expect to have
quantum engines in our garages anytime
soon
but
quantum control is developing and
i as a theorist
long thought that basically anything i
proposed would be laughed at because
theorists have a reputation for
proposing experiments that are
impossible for the next 20 years but
i've been
very pleasantly surprised at
how often experimentalists have said huh
no yeah i could do that sure let's
collaborate
so
i have
again people have recently performed
the landauer erasure experiment that we
just discussed earlier with a number of
different platforms sailors engine is
very closely related
uh
to my knowledge no one has realized
sealard's engine with these different
types of particles okay but
um
i have discussed it with some
experimentalists and they say there's at
least one lab out there that can
probably do the experiment now
with some significant thought so
in a few years and 10 years
uh experimentalists will have much
better control so i don't want to say
that they can't do something
and i want to help the audience really
just visualize what's going on here so a
real engine like in a car in a gas car
uh i put gas into it there's some fuel
and it burns the fuel increases entropy
makes the car go uh what what are the
analogous things for your little tiny
quantum engine what is the fuel that
makes it go
the fuel
you could think of as consisting of two
parts
one is the heat from the environment
from the heat bath but again this is
random uncoordinated energy so we have
to have so to speak some way of
directing it
and we use our information in order to
direct it for instance
in the case of sealer's engine we have
once again a gas in a box
and
we could imagine the box being
partitioned in half
and suppose that we have one bit of
information about the gas suppose in a
really simple example the gas is just
one particle and we know that the
particle is on the right hand side of
the box rather than the left hand side
of the box
then we can hook up a weight
so that
if we allow the partition to move so
that the particle
knocks against the partition and is able
to move it farther and farther and
farther across the box
as the partition moves it drags a weight
upward
okay
then
we're using our information about which
side the particle is on
in order to
decide where to put the weight
and
that's what enables the particle to
get heat energy from the bath and lift
the weight
by the end of this process the particle
has pushed the partition all the way to
the edge of the box so that again the
particle is free to be absolutely
anywhere in the box we have no idea
where the particle is so we have lost
our information about the particle but
in exchange we've lifted the weight and
i
don't know that i could necessarily
describe very well exactly how you would
hook up the weight so that it is um
being dragged but
there's a beautiful illustration in my
book that i did not draw
a wonderful steampunk artist drew it so
there's more information there
and so in some sense you're being
maxwell's demon you're using information
to sort of figure out how to extract
some work from these randomly
fluctuating particles
you could think about it that way and
you could see that as a reason why
one could say that charlie bennett was
building on the work of silard and
landar
in proposing a resolution to maxwell's
demon paradox
and is this kind of thing
[Music]
i guess the question trying to get to is
separate out
the quantumness of it from the tininess
of it like part of this whole discussion
is just that we're at the level of
particles and atoms and things like that
and even if the world had been classical
you would have to think a little bit
differently than we do in the big
macroscopic world another part of it is
that the world is not classical it's
really quantum mechanical and there's
contextuality and entanglement so is
this engine you're describing really
using quantumness or is it just relying
on the fact that things are tiny the
engine that i just described in detail
can work even if the particle is
classical
that's why
a group
of people who came around much later
than sealard built on his idea by saying
suppose that we move from thinking about
one particle to thinking about
multiple particles and suppose that
these multiple particles were classical
or fermions or bosons so their results
relied on
the statistics of fermions and bosons
fermions obey pauli's exclusion
principle so as you said
two particles that two fermions can't
pile on top of each other they can't be
in exactly the same quantum state
whereas
bosons do like to be in the same quantum
state and so can be bunched up together
okay very good and our i mean since this
is happening down the level of particles
and molecules etc uh i can imagine this
is going to be useful for nanotechnology
is it useful in
biology do you like cells use this kind
of uh
these kinds of structures to move
themselves around or is it something
only human beings have caught on to
that's something we'd like to know more
about there is a subfield of quantum
biology that is
enjoying uh extra energy nowadays
and
um people approach the
quantum biology from many different
angles in general it is
very hard to find a way in which
non-classical phenomena could be
having a large scale effect in biology
because biological systems are
warm they're watery they tend to be
large
and in these conditions quantum
phenomena such as entanglement tend to
die off quickly
however
their
quantum theory is certainly relevant to
molecules molecules are certainly
relevant to biology for instance i had
the privilege and pleasure of working
with a chemist david limmer at uc
berkeley he studies photoisomers which
are molecular switches
they're molecules that have one
conformation
most of the time but when
light hits them and they absorb a photon
they have the opportunity to switch
configuration
so he was studying these molecules in
many different ways people have plenty
of models for them
but these molecules are small they are
quantum they're far from equilibrium
and
so models tend to be either very very
detailed or to involve some assumptions
that we might prefer not to make
so
we work together to try to make a
more general model using quantum
information theory and derive a general
bound on the probability that one of
these molecular one of these molecules
would switch
um
you could probably recast that in terms
of
uh
quantum well this is a quantum thermal
machine a molecular switch
we weren't thinking of it as an engine
but
one can often think about such things as
quantum thermal machines so they are out
there although
um their large scale effects on biology
as far as we know are probably fairly
small but there could be plenty to be
discovered
i think maybe it's worth you know
helping the audience
gain this intuition that physicists have
that warm wet things won't be quantum
mechanical right um uh quantum mechanics
is the world the whole world is quantum
mechanical but classical physics is a
pretty good approximation to it and it
becomes a very good approximation when
things are big and radiating and and so
forth i mean can you explain a little
bit more about why that is and therefore
why
intrinsically quantum phenomena are not
even more ubiquitous in biology
sure and we can use entanglement as a
touchstone
you mentioned that you think of
intaining goldman as particularly
quantum i i really do too i think it's a
useful way to think in many cases
so suppose that
we
were interested in finding some
biological system
that makes use of entanglement so this
entanglement would need to be
concentrated and controlled between the
few systems that would need to be
entangled
it's all too easy to entangle particles
particles very easily entangle with
stray particles the things that bump
into them especially if the temperature
is high things are jiggling around a
whole lot
so even if you start even if two
molecules or
one molecule started out with some
controlled entanglement that it might be
able to
take advantage of to perform
some
tasks thermodynamic or information
processing
probably that entanglement would
dissipate very quickly to the
environment because of the principle of
monogamy of entanglement one particle
can share only so much entanglement with
any other particles
so
this particle could share a whole bunch
of concentrated entanglement with one
other particle to do something
useful
or
if this particle gets distracted by
other particles then it would end up
sharing only a little bit of
entanglement which each with each of the
other particles and there would be
no particle with which it shares enough
entanglement that it could accomplish
something useful from that entanglement
okay let me let me try to rephrase that
because there's an interesting
perspective that i haven't heard before
given that
uh there's sort of an upper amount of
entanglement you can have when particles
are when there's lots of particles and
they keep bumping into each other they
will be entangled but the amount of
entanglement between one particle and
any other one particle will be really
really tiny because the entanglement
gets spread
all over the place and therefore
this seems like a bit of a leap but
therefore
it's almost as if there's no
entanglement at all
right suppose that we
as humans to make this a relatively
clean example as humans who have
conscious agency
wanted to
send some quantum message from me to you
so we could do that in two ways we could
have a quantum channel
analogous to the internet that we're
using now but quantum
and i could send my message over that
quantum channel
instead we could
just share two particles
two
qubits two basic units of quantum
information that are maximally entangled
and we could perform a certain protocol
on them
such that it would be as though we had
one use of a quantum channel
so
to
do something useful to send a unit
amount of quantum information
we would need or yeah to send some
amount of quantum information
we would need at least this one
maximally entangled pair
and if we had just
a pair of particles that were
very distracted by the other particles
around them so that um your particle and
my particle didn't share enough
entanglement then we couldn't accomplish
a useful quantum task
it's interesting because it's it's it's
always a bit of a surprise to me even
though i know it's true that the world
is so very very quantum and yet we have
to work really hard to manifest its
quantumness in some places yeah that's
it's very interesting
and even
uh before quantum mechanics comes along
there's there's this uh in statistical
mechanics there's this concept of
fluctuations right of uh if we don't
know if we don't have perfect
knowledge information of the state of
all of our particles uh we can say what
usually happens but there will be
fluctuations around that and i mean
maybe you can help us because i don't
think we've ever talked about it on the
podcast but there's been a bit of a
revolution in
this non-equilibrium fluctuation kind of
statistical mechanics over the last 20
years uh that is
even in the classical world and now
these days in the quantum world yes
so there's this
field of
non-equilibrium thermodynamics or
statistical mechanics called fluctuation
relations fluctuation relations are
can be thought of as
stronger versions of the second law so
the second law of thermodynamics is an
inequality as you stated near the
beginning of the podcast according to
the second law of thermodynamics the
entropy of a closed isolated system
increases or stays constant
so it obeys an inequality over time
and the second law of thermodynamics in
most cases doesn't tell us how much the
entropy will increase it just says right
it'll increase
some amount or stay constant so that is
that's some information but it's not as
much information as one can want
fluctuation relations are equalities
and they're
they govern systems even very far from
equilibrium which is
a state in which
the large-scale properties of a system
such as its temperature and pressure
remain constant and there are no net
flows of anything into or out of the
system so it's a very idealized state
most of the worlds that we care about is
that of equilibrium we are far from
equilibrium
so fluctuation relations are these
stronger versions of the second law of
thermodynamics but from them you can
recover what's sometimes called
the second law of thermodynamics and
they give us also more information in
that if you
perform the same experiment many many
times
then you might get different outcomes in
different trials for instance suppose
that you have a strand of dna you can
trap one end of it in an optical trap
using a laser and
use lasers to stretch the strand of dna
and stretching something requires the
input of energy it requires work
so you can imagine starting the strand
out in the same way in each of many many
experiments and in each experiment
stretching the dna strand through the
same distance
in different trials you'll need
different amounts of work because in one
experiment a water molecule kicks the
molecule over here in this direction
in another experiment or another trial a
water molecule kicks the dna over there
in a different direction so different
trials require different amounts of work
but you can perform many many trials and
from the statistics predict that in the
next trial you'll
need
this amount of work and from some
fluctuation relations we can
learn about the probability of the next
trial
um
we can do all sorts of things with
fluctuation relations some are practical
some are fundamental
um have to
mention my institution i feel sort of
legally obliged
but the university of maryland is home
to my colleague and collaborator chris
jarzinski who is responsible for
czarzinski's equality which is one of
these fluctuation relations one of the
ones that helps to kick off a lot of
excitement about what they could say in
detail about these
far from equilibrium systems that are
usually extremely difficult to describe
except chris is very humble so everyone
else calls it jerseys he's equality and
he calls it the non-equilibrium
fluctuation relation which i think is um
much less convenient to say
but
it's these equalities are remarkable not
only for the reasons i've mentioned but
also because
the world far from equilibrium tends to
be very difficult to describe it's
chaotic it's wild it's difficult to
derive very general results that
describe lots of non-equilibrium
situations but these fluctuation
relations do and they're not only
theoretical constructs that have just
been proved mathematically they've been
tested with dna with rna with other
small particles and extensions of them
have been
explored with quantum systems and more
let me just as an aside it's interesting
that you keep mentioning dna because it
took a while for this to get into my
brain but we think of dna as what
carries the genetic information inside
our cells but to physicists it's like a
really good spring or
something like that it's a very flexible
molecule for tiny tiny applications
right
yes to physicists most things are
springs
it has nothing to do with which base
pairs are being used in the dna you're
not using that information that's that's
interesting and fun
and yeah so this uh i mean i i don't
know i'm asking you open-ended questions
here because i just want to hear your
your big picture views but
to me um
these fluctuation theorems these
non-equilibrium statements these
statements about how thermodynamics
works when things are not settled down
and the gas is not all
equilibrated inside the box um
we're beginning to put
to get a handle on how that works and
this might have enormous
uh implications for you know how complex
systems work in general like you already
said um it's hard to get general rules
in these cases and here's a general rule
so can we imagine bootstrapping our way
up from those rules that we have to
a bigger picture understanding of things
beyond individual particles things which
have many moving parts but aren't simple
like a box of gas
certainly and i i think that the field
of complexity science is very exciting i
know you belong to the santa fe
institute so you have a bunch of
colleagues thinking about complexity
theory
i've even written a paper about
complexity theory in that sense recently
the regimes
certainly share
the importance of information in some
cases they share the importance of
thermodynamics
in some ways they are a little bit
different
fluctuation relations are
especially useful when the system is
small
if a system is large then it will
very often
behave as it does on average
and fluctuations away from the average
have less and less significance so
that's one reason why fluctuation
relations have been tested with strands
of dna and rna they're small enough that
the fluctuations are very important
but also i agree complex systems are far
from equilibrium so there can certainly
be overlaps in those toolkits
yeah i mean i guess the intuition i have
which is very vague on mathematical at
this point in my in my thought about it
but
what makes complex systems interesting
is there can be feedback between
different levels right even though it's
a big system like a simple system is the
earth going around the sun even though
the earth has made lots of particles we
can pretty accurately predict where it
is but one system has become complex
like a person or a volcano or a
hurricane i can imagine tiny little
fluctuations at the microscopic level uh
impacting the macroscopic behavior in
interesting ways that's why i'm
wondering whether or not there are
connections to be drawn there that's all
i have to say it's very vague but
i figured i'd put on the table
there
there's certainly a lot of work in that
direction
i've also had the privilege and pleasure
of working with jeremy england
group
um he and his group have had extremely
interesting ideas about fluctuation
relations complex systems far from
equilibrium systems self-organizing
systems so they do very rigorous far
from equilibrium statistical mechanics
and in part it was a pleasure to work
with him because he is such a rigorous
thinker about statistical mechanics but
the group is inspired by
thoughts of life which is
certainly a complex system
and
um there are
and so there are connections between the
fluctuation relations that are
particularly visible in small systems
and
larger systems such as living systems
i will mention that jeremy was a former
mindscape guest so you're uh it's a we
have a good track record there um
good but that but i know that was a long
digression because i just love the
fluctuation theorems but i do want to
hit back on a couple more quantum points
before we wrap up um
one of the fascinating crucial things
about quantum mechanics is the role of
measurements and observations right
we've talked about entanglement a little
bit which i think
is pretty central i mean as a many
worlds person i think entanglement is
the only thing you need to know and you
can derive everything else but certainly
operationally in the real world when you
measure quantum systems their wave
functions look like they collapse
uh how important is that kind of
measurement uncertainty in quantum
mechanics which wasn't there in
classical mechanics to this story of uh
statistical mechanics and thermodynamics
at the at the micro scale how important
is wave function collapse to quantum
steampunk thinking it's very important
measurement
is how we learn about properties of a
system
and we
in as thermodynamicists would like to
know how much work we've performed on a
system how much work we've extracted
from it how much heat is it's exchanged
with its surroundings
but we find out those properties
typically by
measuring the system of interest and if
we measure the system of interest then
we disturb it and we can
influence
our understanding of how much energy the
system has absorbed or let go
so there is a
problem of defining quantum heat and
quantum work that has been the subject
of a lot of debate i have a
folder that i keep
every time i find another paper that
proposes another definition of quantum
work and heat i add it to the folder
but i think that that's actually
a reason for some of the richness of
quantum thermodynamics
i
haven't proposed definitions of quantum
work in heat myself but partially
because there are definitions that i
think
are quite useful in different settings
that i consider
and
i think that this richness
can be interestingly contrasted with say
particle physics
the physicists are stereotyped as being
obsessed with unification trying to take
a whole bunch of different theories and
show that they're really the same theory
so that there's just one theory to rule
them all
but
in quantum thermodynamics there are
these many different definitions of work
and heat that seem to be useful
depending on how you poke the system
how you perform work on the system how
you measure the system whether you have
any other systems around to help you in
particular ways
and
so they're
my opinion which seems to be the opinion
of at least some other quantum
thermodynamicists is there might not be
any one definition of quantum work and
heat to rule them all but maybe there
doesn't need to be because there are
diverse situations we approach different
systems in different ways with different
tools and different skills
and
different definitions and measurement
strategies can be useful in different
situations so
the measurement of
or the disturbance of a quantum system
by measurement is extremely
fundamentally important in quantum
thermodynamics good i figured it was i i
wanted to check because you these
sometimes you get surprising answers in
this in this field that's why you need
to do the research i guess uh okay so i
mean at the end of the podcast i always
like to allow ourselves to be a little
bit more speculative uh than in the meat
of the podcast so
uh imagine that rather than being a
professor and podcaster i was a venture
capitalist uh and i wanted to know how
to spend my money on quantum steampunk
startup companies like what are the
things that we might hope even if it's
not in the very near term but what are
the
real world technological applications
that we might want to get out of this is
it mostly mini engines or uh time
keeping or or is there even biological
medicinal kind of applications for this
kind of technology
i think that's a very important question
and
one that i think that the field
could benefit from increasingly
addressing
as i mentioned the roots of quantum
thermodynamics and a lot of the quantum
thermodynamics that has been done has
been
relatively abstract mathematical and
theoretical
quantum thermodynamics has made its way
into experiments and the number of
experiments and the complexity of the
experiments has been growing and it will
continue to grow
but thermodynamics
did develop hand in hand with the
industrial revolution which was
extremely useful that was useful yeah
also there were some downsides of it but
mostly yeah it was useful there were
certainly downsides hopefully we can
learn from past mistakes
so it would be
lovely if
also quantum thermodynamics could go
hand in hand with
some quantum thermodynamic technologies
those
on a practical level don't yet exist the
engines that we propose have been really
useful for seeing the difference between
quantum physics and classical physics
through the lens of thermodynamic tasks
similarly to how we understand
that nowadays how quantum differs from
classical by understanding what
problems a quantum computer can solve
much more efficiently than a classical
computer and the experiments have been
proof of principle experiments
but now that we
have done some of this fundamental leg
work
and
we have started on and done a number of
proof of principle experiments i think
it definitely would be useful to think
about
how quantum thermodynamics could help us
technologically
so i
uh one challenge is that
quantum systems are
very difficult to control so i
like to look for
what i think of as quantum analogues of
southern california
southern california is uh it just
happens to be very well suited to solar
panels
and
so if you just stick some solar panels
in southern california then
even though the solar panels need rather
specific conditions to work well they
will work well if they're put in the
right place
so i think there might be some
situations that might already exist in
labs in which we could stick a quantum
thermodynamic device
and get some benefit i'm working with a
lab on
one possible way of realizing this idea
they've asked me not to talk much about
it so
much for now um and also i'm not the
only person thinking in this direction
alexia fev in
france has also recently written some
papers about
the
possibilities for quantum thermodynamic
technologies
i think that all the ideas you mentioned
are interesting to think about
i don't know if we will succeed in
making
many very useful quantum thermodynamic
technologies i hope so just we haven't
thought about it too much yet so i think
there's a lot of opportunity
okay but i'm not you know i'm pretending
to be a venture capitalist now not not a
podcaster i want you to tell me what one
technology i should spend my money on
if you're a venture capitalist i'm
afraid i'm the wrong person to talk to
but um yeah
perhaps a quantum engine that is
sort of placed in the right way in a lab
so that it can take advantage of
the quantum control that's naturally
there
well not naturally but already there
and use the resources around it and i i
should probably for
due to the request of my colleague not
say too much okay i know that that is
unfair um but uh
are there potential i mean just as a
sort of uh
guidance as to what to be aware of
or looking for as the future comes on
line um
uh solar power is that something that
will be maybe useful uh these quantum
techniques
there are
certainly people thinking about
um how we can capture energy from light
more efficiently for instance my
chemist colleague at uc berkeley and
um
there
quantum physics energy and information
are all relevant so the quantum
thermodynamics community has been
historically a little separate from that
but i think it would be useful to create
some more of those bridges
okay and then on the totally opposite
side not being a venture capitalist
anymore final question are there
connections and maybe the answer is no
but are there connections here to other
things
going on in quantum information theory
like quantum computing
or even applications of quantum
information to black holes in emergent
space-time absolutely that's one of the
frontiers that i think is most exciting
for quantum thermodynamics and quantum
steampunk which i think of as sort of
taking the
not only building a theory of quantum
thermodynamics marrying
quantum physics with
thermodynamics sometimes with help from
information theory but also taking the
mathematical and conceptual tools of
this quantum theory of thermodynamics
taking it around to different
disciplines and saying how can we help
with our toolkits or can we undercover
any new questions or can we take
inspiration from your field to ask new
questions about quantum thermodynamics
so i've had
again the privilege and pleasure of
working with people in
chemistry condensed matter atomic
molecular and optical physics and high
energy and black hole physics
it's
definitely a lot of fun to cross these
borders and very productive
i
often feel very ignorant because i'm
usually talking with people
whose conversation i don't understand
but it's
it's a wonderful feeling to be able to
say
you have this problem and i think that
this tool from quantum thermodynamics
could help i gave the example earlier of
the
chemist david lemmer
who was thinking about a molecular
switch so we used a tool from quantum
thermodynamics a resource theory a very
simple mathematical model for quantum
thermodynamics in order to
derive the bound that he was looking for
so those connections definitely
exist some of my colleagues and i are
working on building many more
yeah i mean it's a good situation to be
in it it can be challenging i think like
like you alluded to because you're
always feeling like you're not the
expert in the room but you have your
little area of expertise that they don't
have and so you're useful to people and
that that is an exciting position for
everyone to be in yes definitely and i'm
looking forward to more and uh good luck
with the book coming out nicole younger
helper and thanks so much for being on
the mind scale
for being on the mindscape podcast
thank you it's been a pleasure
[Music]
you